let's say that you own the only hotel
that is in a city and for a wide variety
of reasons maybe all of the city council
members are your friends or whatever
else no one else can build a hotel in
the city so there are insurmountable
barriers to entry so in that situation
you would have a monopoly you are the
only player in the market and there are
very very high barriers to entry
now this is a typical cost structure and
demand curve for a monopoly we've
already talked about your marginal cost
might dip down a little initially but
then it might go up and we could debate
whether that would be true for a hotel
or not but this is the typical model we
see and then while your marginal cost is
below average total cost average total
cost trends down and then hits a minimum
point where marginal cost intersects it
and then it starts to trend up as
marginal cost is higher than that
and the demand curve for monopoly looks
familiar when the prices are high if the
prices on the hotel rooms per night are
high very few people will demand them
and if the prices are low a lot of folks
would demand them now something that
we've talked about in a lot of detail in
other videos is how the marginal revenue
curve is different than the demand curve
for a monopoly and that's because if you
were to charge a price of let's say 500
per room you might be able to get one
room
one room rented out for the night but no
other rooms and if you wanted to get two
rooms rented out well you would have to
charge four hundred dollars
not just for that room so now we get a
little bit further down this demand
curve but when you charge four hundred
dollars maybe for that second room
because someone's willingness to pay is
four hundred dollars well you might have
to also charge 400 for that first room
so in many monopoly industries whatever
you charge to one consumer you have to
charge to other consumers now i know
what some of you are thinking hey that
doesn't always happen in a hotel and
that's why i picked this example because
we're going to look at the situation
where one you do have to charge the same
to everyone and then we'll look at
another situation known as price
discrimination where you don't have to
charge the same to everyone let's just
go with the model where you do have to
change the same to everyone so when you
go from one room at 500 to two rooms at
400 your marginal revenue isn't the
incremental 400 because this 500 is now
400 as well so you go from 500 to 800 so
your marginal revenue is an incremental
300 as you go from 500 total to 400 plus
400 or 800 total and that's why we go
into significant detail in other videos
on this and we do it with tables of
numbers and i encourage you to do that
and that is why your marginal revenue
curve for a monopoly has twice the slope
the negative slope than your demand
curve would have so your marginal
revenue curve would look something like
this and we've already talked about in
multiple videos for any firm it's
rational to produce the quantity where
marginal cost is equal to marginal
revenue so this monopoly would produce
this
quantity
and the price they would get well that
quantity we go to look at the demand
curve the price would be right over
there so this monopoly firm would be
able to get that price
and we can think about what its economic
profit would be
on every room in this case it charges
that price and it is and its average
total cost is this blue line right over
here so its average total costs are
there so the difference is how much
economic profit per room and then you
multiply that times the total number of
rooms and so this area is the firm's
economic profit
now there's still some consumer surplus
here this is benefit that consumers are
getting above and beyond what they're
paying for it so the consumer surplus in
this situation would be all of this so
that first person who's willing to pay
maybe 500 dollars per room is now able
to get this market price that everyone
is able to get
which is maybe 300 per room and so this
benefit for that one unit it goes to the
consumer
and we've also seen that there is
deadweight loss here you're allocatively
efficient when marginal cost is equal to
the demand curve and so we studied that
in other videos this right over here is
our deadweight loss
but now let's imagine the other scenario
let's say that we are a hotel where we
try to capture as much of someone's
willingness to pay as possible and i'll
give a little bit of a
idealistic scenario that doesn't really
exist in the world real world but just
to look at an extreme case let's say
that you were able to get a con a
computer that can read people's minds
and every time they call for a quote on
a room you know exactly what their
willingness to pay is so if i call the
computer says hey sal's willingness to
pay for that room is 375 dollars so you
quote me all right 375 dollars i say
okay sure and then when that first
person who has a high willingness to pay
calls it says okay why don't we quote
them 500
and so we quote them 500 and so they get
that room and so in that situation
every incremental room you don't have to
change the prices on all the other ones
causing this marginal revenue curve to
slope down faster instead every
incremental room you get those dollars
and so in that situation your demand
curve is equal to
your marginal revenue curve you're able
to discriminate on prices let me write
this this is price
discrimination
you're able to charge and price
discrimination is a general term for
charging different customers different
consumers different rates ideally based
on their willingness to pay and it might
sound bad we in normal life we don't
like discriminating against others but
price discrimination is a very
legitimate thing and actually you will
see it happen in things like the hotel
industry where they're going to try to
charge different prices to different
people based on their willingness to pay
for essentially the same room if you go
stay in a hotel it's very likely that
the person in an identical room next to
you is paying a different rate airlines
will also do it now they're not going to
be able to do it as perfectly as i just
described with this magical computer but
they'll do it where depending on how far
ahead or whether you can return the
ticket or cancel your reservation you
could get a different price and the
prices change over time and so they're
trying to capture as much of consumers
willingness to pay as possible but if we
took this extreme situation where you're
able to charge exactly everyone their
willingness to pay
well then what is going to be the
rational quantity for this profit
maximizing monopoly to produce
well once again it would be where
marginal cost intersects marginal
revenue but the marginal revenue curve
is now the demand curve
so it'd be right over there that's the
quantity that this monopoly would
produce and then what's the price it
would get
pause this video and think about that
well you might be tempted to just go
horizontally here and say okay this is
the price it would get like we did here
but remember it's able to get a
different price for every consumer so
there isn't just one price like in this
first example that everyone is paying
so we can see the quantity it is
producing you can see the average total
cost at that quantity
but the profit per room is going to be
dependent on what people are willing to
pay this first person is going to pay a
lot for it and so they're not going to
get much of or they're not going to get
any consumer surplus in this extreme
example and so all of this is going to
accrue to the firm
and that's going to be the case for all
of these consumers in this extreme
circumstance and so now you have a
fascinating situation
notice when this monopoly firm is able
to do price discrimination now its
economic profit is far larger economic
profit
the consumer surplus shrunk through
price discrimination and the extreme
example disappeared but you also see
that this is actually allocatively
efficient that we are actually producing
at a quantity where marginal cost is
equal to marginal revenue